hello everybody and welcome back to
murder mystery moon
you guys requested another one of these
and i'm so happy because i love true
crime but i kind of get hardcore like i
really need to like
research a lot so a lot of this airbnb
trip i was just researching more and
more and more because i just keep
finding new pieces of information i just
think it's juicy
anyway now we have drinks and that's the
first
[Music]
must have drinks yeah we'll get there
yeah
we'll start back on it i don't know what
this is called uh santa slaughter yeah
we'll call it that
so right off the top of your head nice
like she's a
trained improviser or if santa's slick
got slayed
santa slain with the ho ho hos yes
so if you want to make it at home it's
really easy i just got some pre-made hot
chocolate from the store you could grab
a packet of hot chocolate if you want to
get fancy you can make your own hot
chocolate
super easy to make but we did a pre-made
version and i just warmed up some milk
i used cashew milk but you can use
regular if you want or you could use
water but honestly
milk or something that's creamy will
help mask the alcohol flavor so i highly
recommend that as opposed to water
um and then you're going to want to grab
three alcohols i mean you could
switch these ingredients out but these
are the ones that i think are the best
in this particular drink
and that is an ounce and a half of
bailey's an ounce of kahlua
and then a half an ounce of creme de
cacao and you're going to stir
all of that together top it with some
marshmallows and we did a little splash
of grenadine on the top to represent
blood because it's spooky brave of you
too
assume that i know what an illness looks
like but thank you just dump it in there
there's measurements for it you could
use a little measurement
there's a recipe but who cares alcohol
to taste everyone
yeah and also i feel like if you're
super lazy you could probably just dump
some baileys in there and call
it and call it a day it's true about
anything else yeah
here's the thing i've i've tested quite
a few alcoholic beverages
um that are like hot beverages and i
don't feel like bailey's
gives me any buzz it's not enough it
doesn't give me any buzz but
mixed with kahlua you could just dump
some babies in the cacao what about
baileys and vodka now you're talking
that works too but you will taste the
vodka right you will definitely taste
the vodka well
unless you get a flavored vodka maybe
that would work but oh yeah you know try
it out
it flavored vodka we're talking about uh
murder today
and it's very sad because this
particular murder still goes unsolved
even though it was
40 years ago almost 40 years ago
yeah and it should have been solved i
feel like by now but
um also i wanted to say this murder took
place around christmas time which is why
i chose this particular yes
we wanted christmas themed murder what's
the matter jesus is delicious
oh thank you why do i get these eyes on
my cup
cut that gina i'm allowed to say it all
right i'm asian
we gave her it's a white man so my
cookie is a white man
oh my gosh gina she just left she's just
you know your friend he got eaten you
can't show
cookie got eaten i ate it i ate yes
yeah it was vietnamese not chinese it
was vietnamese you need to stop
it was mixing up cultures there's a
trend here i'm feeling attacked but
okay back to this murder sorry oh my god
that was probably made in china
that's probably why it looks like to
them
anyways also fun fact um did you know
that back in the day they used to
gather around a campfire or a fireplace
and tell ghost stories on christmas
oh because christmas was kind of like a
wicked thing right i don't know
yeah before chris pagan before uh you
know that song that's like
we'll tell scary ghost stories and tales
of the glories of christmas
oh my god i didn't even realize yeah
right and then even like the ghost of
christmas anyway this isn't a ghost
story at all it's a true crime story
and i want to set the tone because this
took
place in a really small town what you
like that drink strong
it's strong it's hitting her right in
the right in the butt right in the [ __ ]
anyway spicy so this takes place in a
really small town of burke county
north carolina and this is the murder of
rhonda henson now when i first looked up
this murder case
this murder case yes i was just looking
up like
murders that happened around christmas
time and i would come across
uh videos and different articles of like
various murders that happened around
christmas
a lot of people get murdered around
christmas time it's kind of crazy i
think these emotions are high you know
like breakups and winter
winter blues people are lonely people
are resentful everyone's happy and so
people that aren't happy are like oh i'm
not happy and so misery loves company
but there wasn't a lot of information
about this case so
originally i kind of brushed over it i
saw the unsolved mystery episode that
came out
originally in 1989 or 85.
when i was born oh no one of those two
years
it was an odd number but 1985 and they
didn't really have a lot of information
to go off so this was the original
case that everybody talks about any
video that you watch it all talks about
this
this is how the case goes so rhonda
hinson was 19 years old
she was on her way to a company uh a
company christmas party
and after the company christmas party
she was going to
stay at a friend's house um one of her
co-workers that lived nearby
and uh what happened was she went to her
friend's house but then she only ended
up staying
for a few minutes and she decided to
actually drive back home to spend the
night
on her way home she never made it
because
she was shot faithfully in the back of
her
while she was driving um a bullet had
gone through
the trunk of her car and the back seat
of her car
and punctured through her heart turning
her dead
on the spot she had maybe 10 to 15
seconds of consciousness
but then she must have been dead uh you
know after
the autopsy like found the trajectory of
the bullet they're like yeah there's no
way she would have been conscious
however when she was found her body was
actually found
outside of the car a few feet from the
car
and her hands were positioned
deliberately by her side
yeah so a couple weird things happened
um
leading up to her death as well her mom
had a premonition while this was
happening she woke up in the middle of
the night
by the way this was december 22nd at
approximately 12 30 a.m
uh yeah and so the mom actually woke up
in the middle of the night and
had a feeling that something bad
happened to her daughter and
the feeling was so strong that she made
her husband she tried to go back to
sleep a few times but then she was like
no i can't ignore this feeling and she
made her husband turn on the radio
and almost immediately reports came on
the radio
of a car accident that happened in the
area so
the mom was kind of freaking out she
didn't want it to be true so she sent
her um son bobby to go see who it was
well it ended up being her daughter
rhonda i know
other strange incidences that happened
in the weeks before ronda's death
were that um she started getting really
scared to go places alone
and she like would ask her dad to like
please accompany me everywhere i go
she didn't want to be anywhere alone um
she also would wake up frequently in the
middle of the night
because she had trouble sleeping and she
would um
shower she would take lots of showers
and so one time her mom was like
why are you showering in the middle of
the night constantly and she said she
just feels dirty
which is a common yeah a common thing
that happens with rake
rape victims or sexual assault victims
though this has never been confirmed
um another weird thing is um because of
the insomnia she would
beg to sleep in her parents room often
she would fall asleep on the floor
near the foot of their bed and then she
would beg to like sleep
in the same room with her brother she
even offered to pay her brother to let
her sleep in his room because she just
did something happen to her she doesn't
want to be alone yeah she does not want
to be sushi again
she was 19. oh yeah and she was never
like this before she was always like
pretty bubbly
a good student a good athlete she was
actually a star athlete she was on
basketball teams and
she was like a star tennis player um she
was in a ton of different sports but
tennis was like her main one oh i love
tennis yeah she would have been your
friend yeah she would have been my
friend
yeah um yeah and then uh also um
at one point her and her mom were
getting ready um and
her mom they were in the bathroom
together and she asked her mom randomly
if it would ever be okay to be with a
married man
and her mother all right her mom said no
that would hurt somebody it seems pretty
obvious where this story is going but i
feel like you wouldn't pick
such an obvious story you know i
thought that maybe because it's an
unsolved mystery i was like
well i love playing drunk detective i'm
like i'ma figure this [ __ ] out yes but
the more i dug the more i was like what
so this i'm telling you what the facts
were based on the unsolved mystery
episode that came out
when it was first publicly released and
then weirdly it hadn't been updated
for like decades like forever this was
the only information that people knew
so um you know at this point what are
you guys thinking
yeah hearing that she got raped by a
teacher or something or like some
like other like a married man in her
life
and that's the reason why she felt so
dirty and why she even asked that she
probably feels guilty or something and
then the man didn't want her telling
anyone so he would hunt her down
yeah and killed her so she wouldn't tell
anyone i'm imagining it's someone a
little bit more high profile in the town
it could be like a pastor
it could be like governor somebody
somebody a little bit more
high profile than a teacher but if she
wasn't a lot of sports it could have
been a coach or something
yeah but yeah it just sounds like
somebody who is married
who maybe she kind of had a crush on
like younger women sometimes do
fantasize about older men be
well before they really understand what
they're getting themselves into and then
when the sex part comes then they might
freak out so then maybe he raped her
and then now she didn't want to say
anything but then maybe he was just like
oh she's not handling it well i got to
get rid of her
yeah that's what it sounds like and then
also something eerie um
you know the friend's house that she was
supposed to spend the night at she had
had gone to the friend's house and they
were all like getting ready for bed
and uh she made a phone call and then
getting off the phone call she said
oh i guess i met her i better go then
and then she
decided to go oh she said i guess i
better go then on the phone like
in front of her yeah kind of in a solemn
tone by the way rhonda was like a person
that kind of kept her business to
herself
so it was really hard she was she didn't
just talk about her problems all the
time
and then do do we know if like the cops
ever looked into the phone records to
see who she spoke with
yeah so we do know that but that wasn't
disclosed in the original episode and i
don't know why like i don't know why
they
kept it so i wonder if some of those
episodes were like
um there was a little bit of politics
around why they wouldn't tell
like some parts of the story like maybe
they're they had an idea of a suspicion
of who it was but they didn't want to
get sued
because they're like there's not enough
so then it would be liable or whatever
yeah that could be the only other
information they gave in the episode
were
witness accounts of the scene of the
crime scene
um there were there was a person that
had been driving
right before the murder happened and
recounted
a car that was parked under the overpass
that was
a dark blue they described it as a
cheville a dark blue cheville that was
kind of messed up in the front
and there were two white males in the in
the
driver and passenger seat and then
another witness
um that was driving after the murder
took place saw
the same a similar car described it
under hypnosis
described a similar car a beat up blue
car
with gray primer on it and there was one
male driver driving very fast the
opposite direction
that he was driving and as he continued
on
about a mile down the road was rhonda's
car in a ditch
and he saw another white male about five
ten to six foot tall with dark brown
hair
that was at the driver's side um door
with a slumped
driver and he just thought that maybe it
was a drunk driving thing like
it was a drunk couple and so he just
didn't think anything of it and he just
kept driving
but those were the two accounts so the
same car
was marked also there was a witness that
described
around that time she saw two cars parked
along the side of the road one was a
beige car
and one was a a toyota and that's all
she said
um we don't know if they're connected
i'm curious about the under hypnosis
part
yeah so one of the witness decided to go
um he agreed to go under hypnosis
because he just wanted to help the case
and under hypnosis he was able to
recount way more details than
before before hypnosis he was like i
think the car was
a cheville a blue cheville um and there
were two drivers
or there were two people in the car but
then under hypnosis he he's like oh it
had gray primer and he
yeah this was the person at the driver's
side window yeah
and that's and that was it for years and
years
so speculation wise you guys are pretty
on the nose with some of the popular
theories yeah um
since there didn't seem to be a motive
for the murder if you talk to any of her
friends and family they were all like
she was the friendliest person ever she
definitely didn't have any enemies she
was so nice to everybody
she like not a bad phone her small town
too right yeah everybody knew everybody
they're like she didn't have anybody
that would be like vengeful against her
so people thought maybe it was because
it was on a highway
that maybe it was like an accidental
thrill kill like teenagers were shooting
at cars
and it accidentally country [ __ ] yeah
exactly and so then they got scared
because they didn't mean to
to do it and so they ran off um another
theory was that
maybe it was the scorned lover of that
married man that she was seeing
or maybe it was the married man that
didn't want the secret to get out
um but either way a lot of people um
ruled out the
thrill kill theory because they were
like
because ronda's window was rolled down
it seemed like she talked to somebody
right before she started driving again
and she would only have stopped for
somebody that she knew
oh so they're saying that they're
they're thinking that she got shot when
the car was stopped
oh no oh yeah they think that she
stopped the car talked to somebody then
started driving off
and got shot because her car threw the
back end through the back
i was thinking that it was from the
trunk yeah i thought someone was in the
trunk oh
no no someone was standing outside the
car okay i was thinking like a man
you know like sometimes you see those
scary movies where like the girl goes to
the grocery store gets back in her car
and there's someone's like in the back
seat
i was thinking like someone popped her
trunk got in her trunk and then just
oh that shot yeah that's insane so
this person had incredible aim to be
able to
shoot outside of the car through the
trunk the back seat and hit her right in
the heart it was only one shot
yeah it was probably an accident it was
a it was that perfect
i don't know guns very well but i think
it's called a 30 caliber
rifle so there was oh was there a sight
on it i wonder
i don't yeah it was like the kind with
the circle target thingy yeah
but they they're just like trying to
gather what the weapon could be if based
off the bullet they don't know the
actual
murder weapon they just know what it
isn't like
what kind of guns couldn't shoot that
bullet yeah and it was only one
shot right yeah you only get one shot
his hat's very good yeah so this was all
the information when i was looking up
christmas
that's that's all that that's all the
information that was there but i was
like
no that's not fair like how could you
like where her family just let that die
but they didn't let it die
good in fact all of these years the case
because it's such a small county
there were thousands of hours going into
this case because it was the biggest
case to happen they don't have anything
else to do yeah but they still
like still no new information was
getting released to the public
until around i think it was like around
2002
this reporter got access to all these
files that were previously um not open
to the public
because i think the family just felt
like you know what
it's been so long like just [ __ ] do
what you gotta do
so she powered through like six inches
of paperwork
and yeah hundreds of lots a lot of hours
it's the national average yeah a lot of
brothers the national average
is actually more than the national
average more than the national average
of paperwork she powered through it
yeah she got in there she goes through
she made it she made it worse
she made it work out yeah good for her
um so she came out with this
article series that uh then continued
through 2019
not her continuing it but people picked
up this article series and
as more information came out um so much
stuff got revealed from then to 2019
that previously
was not released and yet no one has
really
updated on like a massive scale um
so here's what i found and i wanna
i wanna know what you guys think because
it sounds like there's
um three main suspects
but really i feel like it's gotta be
down to two
okay okay let's see if we'll knock the
same one out that you knocked out okay
wow here we go so as i mentioned before
after examining examining multiple
angles and bullet trajectories
detectives have concluded
that this was no random act this was
somebody
that had premeditated this and
typically when you delve into in murder
investigations
you look at the people closest to the
victim
first right you look at friends and you
look at families so but there were so
many people that were left uninterviewed
or at least the interviews did not go to
the public or weren't put together
in a case there were dead ends you know
if you want to have a nice smile and
straight teeth but you weren't born that
way
like guess what you could like you if
you weren't born though
like yeah if you weren't straight like
yes yeah i was born with straight tails
and [ __ ] up and you did
you don't want to go through three years
of metal braces
um you can pick up some candid aligners
um
candid clear liners are comfortable
removable and totally invisible
unlike braces so you can transform your
smile without anybody noticing
plus your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement
how does that class go like each class
you're just like
observing teeth they must love it
they're like yeah that's moving so
they take 10 000 hours of something to
become an expert too so 10
000 hours of watching teeth move these
people are doing that
right somebody has to do it god bless
them
your treatment includes remote
monitoring by the same orthodontist who
created your plan so you never have to
wonder how you're doing
you'll always know and i love that and
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start
seeing results right uh way before that
so fast wow
the future i yeah and it costs an
average of 50
less than invisalign so start
straightening your teeth today right now
all our listeners can save 75 doll hairs
on candid starter kit go to candidco.com
and use code mood that's candidco.com
mood code mood to take advantage of this
limited
time offer to save 75 on your starter
kit candidco.com
mood code mood yes and once you fix
your crooked teeth you can fix your
crooked brain
with talk space we're all kind of messed
up and we're gonna help you fix it
we're gonna help you okay like okay so
some people
some of y'all need some serious [ __ ]
therapy
some of us just have some things going
on in our life we need someone to talk
to
i'm i'm adding geotag gina needs the
most serious therapy
that you could possibly get um
but the rest of us we just have like
normal life [ __ ] that we're going
through we don't want to
burn out our friends talking about our
problems all the time because maybe we
won't take the advice exactly when they
tell us and how so then they get pissed
off at us
it's great are you attacking yourself
i'm i'm if i'm going to call out gina i
can call you
okay yeah so if you don't want to burn
out your friends and you want to talk to
a licensed therapist talkspace has
a ton of them that you can select from
if you
start with one you realize they're not
really your vibe or whatever you just
in that conversation and then pick
another one right away and i like that
you can kind of
look at their little resume see what
their specialties are like if i'm
dealing with
uh generalized anxiety this person deals
with generalized anxiety this is a good
match for me i'm going to try them out
and one great thing is that talkspace
covers over 40 million people for online
therapy
through their insurance or employer this
is huge like it wasn't like this when
these companies first started now you
can use your insurance this is amazing
the talkspace network is composed of
thousands of licensed therapists
experienced in treating depression
anxiety substance abuse trauma
relationship issues food and eating and
so much more and it's always
very secure and private talking to my
friends is so different from talking to
a licensed therapist who has expertise
and knowledge to give me practical
guidance
talkspace gives us the support we need
at an affordable price
as the listener of this podcast you'll
get 100 off your first month with
talkspace
to match with a licensed therapist today
go to talkspace.com or download the app
make sure to use the code mood to get
100 off your first month and show your
support for the show
that's mood at talkspace.com oh
yeah looking past looking at the
two years leading up to her death it was
discovered that she was dating a guy
she was dating a guy named greg greg
mcdowell all right greg
yeah yeah i see you great looking at you
greg
so greg and ronda started dating her
junior year of high school
and they seemed absolutely smitten with
each other okay
like greg especially he was writing her
so many notes ugh desperate oh my god so
she kept all she kept all the notes
they're all at her parents house
and the public they are was it facebook
official
they didn't have facebook back then this
was the 1980s they were going steady
they were going steady yearbook official
yeah definitely they were actually known
as a hot couple on campus
because she was a star athlete he was a
star at good academian
you know academia honor society or
something
yeah oh you're foreshadowing the nut
part
maybe maybe jess he's a bit of a nut
alleged nut but he nutted
that's true actually we'll get to that
oh
there's nothing
okay the national average amount so the
letters that he was sending her were
super cute okay they were like you know
you're my
little fuzzy lassie that's what he would
call her you're my fuzzy lassie
he would he called her a dog
that was an inside joke talking to him
it might be a drink too
i don't know this old-timey speech from
the 19th
i don't know um yeah so he would write
her little notes
and she had nine notes in all together
of their junior year
and her mother was talking about how
rhonda seemed super happy that first
year
it all changed the second year though
that's when they had sex the second
notes started getting very sinister yeah
it was after she let him nuts
they were kind of um damn her [ __ ] was
that bomb maybe
they were kind of still cute notes but
like with a weird dark
undertone so you can tell from the notes
he would start getting
really really jealous he would write her
apology notes we don't really know what
happened but he would
he'd say things like sorry i said the
things i said but
maybe you could understand you know when
i saw that you
um couldn't wait to see him again i just
really felt like maybe something was
going on and if there's nothing going on
then
you won't mind me beating his ass then
smiley face
please yeah jealous super emotional
energy dude
she started getting he started getting
very possessive also he would get really
passive aggressive when she would tell
him
yeah when he would she said that she
would show up before the bell ring
of um the first period to hang out with
him and then he
she wouldn't show up so he would write
notes like uh you weren't there again
you know and uh even though it makes me
really bad i still really really love
you this guy cannot take a hint
yeah yeah and also he's actually driving
her away with that
yeah psychonauts people don't know that
guys don't do this
girls don't do this either nobody should
nobody should do this
match their energy if they're pulling
back and pull back a little bit it's
okay
things take time yeah and maybe be more
like
interested in what's going on maybe
people are interested in yourself for a
little bit if you guys need some
some space communicating about it if
they walk away
don't run towards them give them some
spaying
yeah and set their house on no tina
nina no don't do that gina um during
this senior year of high school a lot of
her friends and family noticed her
demeanor change so she used to be very
smiley and bubbly
and talk to everybody and then she's a
man entered her life sorry go ahead
maybe so
she got really uh reserved and her
grades started slipping she used to be
like a really
solid eight straight a student and then
her grades started slipping um
she was a lot more somber like she
wasn't as
smiley she's have a contagious smile and
so you can see in greg's notes he
actually
starts getting mad that she's not happy
and will be like like some of the notes
are like i better see you smile again
or else i'll shoot you with my shotgun
just kidding he had one
are you kidding me craig and then he
would write like
where's that smile i used to love
remember i have a shotgun
you crushed it greg you crushed her
smile you better smile i'm gonna
decapitate you yeah
just kidding love your brontosaurus
unicorn
psycho fuzzy brother psycho yeah it was
great
so greg just really really loved her so
much in a disgusting way
yeah in a way that's all about him it's
not even
yeah and then um all of her friends so
she had a best friend named jill
and uh jill turner and jill and
greg left for college so after they
graduated high school
rhonda just wanted to go work right away
she was sick of school she didn't like
it it wasn't her thing anymore
but um jill and her boyfriend greg
went off to college and he would write
her all the time when he was away at
college she would just say how much he
misses her and that he's crying without
her
oh oh i forgot to tell you guys during
the senior year
he also wrote a note that was
apologizing for pushing her
um so he did get physical as well
domestic violence we love to sing
and then there was a note that responded
from um
rhonda which was saying um it was saying
hey thanks a lot for hurting my lip
where my tooth hurts
um not no longer your fuzzy lassie
rhonda so you beat her somehow maybe
that indicates her fire out he killed
her light
and i am obsessed he smothered her flame
i am upset with you greg
yeah so he was writing her letters in
college being like i miss you so much i
miss you so much but every time he would
visit
he'd just get really like skeptical of
anyone she was talking to
or seeing he was like digging into all
of her information
like looking at through journals would
like spy on her
all kinds of stuff like that um at one
point
she came home with a potted plant and
she was he was like or her mom said
where'd you get that potted plant and
she said oh dawn from work gave it to me
and then
greg looked at her like really mad and
ronda was quickly like no he gave him to
everybody in the office and ronda worked
with
greg's mom and she was like watch your
mom has one when you go home you'll see
like she has one too and then she like
rushed to his mom's house to bring
another plant
the same plant yeah
um he also would comment on her weight a
lot like he would send letters being
like
you better lose two pounds by the next
time i see you
i'm tired of great i'm sick of him i
want to beat his
so ass would also get mad if she bought
anything new so
she would spend a portion of her
paycheck buying him something
every time yeah but if she ever bought
anything for herself
greg would like accuse her of wasting
money and whose money [ __ ] my money
exactly
yes can you imagine being married to a
man like that i
cannot thank god for the women that got
all those divorces like leading up to
the modern times so that we can get one
so easily thank you ladies
i love you oh there were so many greg's
that they had to marry him
also this is gonna ding ding ding some
bells in your head
okay um ding me the car
that greg sometimes drove was a blue
chevelle wasn't it it was a blue
nova my scotia nova it looks like a
cheville
my hair has a nova my daddy has another
one and it was [ __ ] up in the front
and had primer on it there we go so
people just don't know cars in that time
yeah i mean it's night time they're
trying to describe what they see
but i i can't remember years in cars i'm
really bad with them
but i believe it was like a 1977
cheville was what was quoted
but in 1970s nova looks just like
it okay maybe the editor can put those
on screen yeah and you can see for
yourself i can't recall what they look
like i had to google them but yeah look
look at look at how similar these look
if someone asked me to describe a car i
honestly can't tell the difference
between a camry and a honda i just can't
like it's the same
can i okay what theory is
greg raped her that's why she felt so
dirty and showering all the time
maybe she leaned on like an appear or
something that's
married also and fell for that married
man like maybe she was trying to
escape her relationship yeah because it
was like an abusive relationship
i tried to kill both of them and then
greg tried to kill her
but i don't know about both but that's
my thought wait going back to what you
were saying about the witness
seeing a driver and then like another
driver slumped
driver that slumped over driver we're
assuming was her was rhonda yeah
okay okay i thought it was a man yeah no
no um yeah there was a man
at the passenger at the driver's window
um
pulling the driver out but she was all
slumped over oh man they saw
the murderer yeah yeah they saw or at
least the aftermath aftermath yeah
they just thought like oh it's a drunk
couple yeah
because they're the guy's car was behind
this car
so there were two people on the site
yeah um yeah so
pretty weird right however there were a
lot of
also weird things um that were
about his father charles mcdowell
the pastor oh she's banging the pasta
about a month before she died um rhonda
was having lunch with her best friend
jill
and recalled the time that she was over
at greg's house and
greg oh they were playing basketball
first and so they were getting really
sweaty and as they went inside greg said
he was going to go take a shower
so ronda went to the kitchen to get
something to eat and all of a sudden she
felt two
arms wrap around her which she assumed
was greg trying to surprise her
but she turned around was her rapey
pastor dad that was
his father craig's father
greg's father charles mcdowell creepy
and then what
like why was he hugging her what the
[ __ ] right yeah
accidentally brush against her a lot
sometimes when she would be in the
bathroom
she would open the door and he'd be
waiting outside for her he freaked her
out like um she also had
lunch with her or not lunch she was
hanging out with her cousin
about a month before her death and they
always told each other their secrets
because
neither of them knew the people in each
other's lives so it was kind of like
whatever i tell you you're not gonna
tell anybody
and she talked about how creeped out she
was by greg's dad
and that she avoided him she would go to
dinner with his family a lot and she
avoided sitting next to him
because he made it a habit of reaching
for her leg under the table
oh creepy yeah i wonder if greg knew
this and he blamed her for it
somehow maybe damn like because he can't
control his dad or maybe his dad beat
him or something maybe his dad convinced
greg that she doesn't want you she look
she look what she did to me
she was like maybe coming on to me a
whole household of toxicity
yeah and yeah so the mom right so she
was like a beloved woman of the church
she was kind of strict like she also
worked with rhonda
and didn't really like talk to many
co-workers like a lot of
her co-workers didn't necessarily like
her they didn't really invite her to
anything
she was just kind of like uptight you
know um
but she would like go to bat for her
family she was like she refused to
believe like any
foul play was happening um but
later it was revealed like a few years
after
ronda's death um that during this time
charles mcdowell was definitely having
affairs with other women
he had placed an ad in the paper
for a female companion and lied to the
person that answered
the ad she started meeting up with this
woman that answered the ad
and he would see her like once a week up
to two times a month
um like between those that amount of
time like not very frequently but like
once a week and during those times he
would lie to her all the time first he
said he wasn't married
then he said he is married but his
wife's in a mental institution
um typical typical that sounds so
60s two fifteen like my wife she's crazy
she's in the nut house
i'm so sad so he pulled this off in a
small town or maybe he was like yeah
he went to different different towns so
they didn't know he was a pastor
number one a public figure yeah number
two married with children
yeah he lied about being a minister and
said that he was
visiting sick children in the hospital
and would have to like go visit him
like the worst people just yeah why are
they all in the church
then also a few years after ronda's
death
there was an anonymous tip that came in
um this person had
rented a p.o box and started getting
weird
mail like at first it was like
frederick's of hollywood type catalogs
would come in
addressed to a charles mcdowell and then
there would be a lingerie store by the
way it's a lingerie store
it's defunct now right yes it's been out
of business
in a long time this is in the 90s this
was in the 90s
and um she then she started getting uh
letters from sex workers that had
pictures of them in negligees
and it would be like come see me next
time you're in town who found this
the this girl that was renting a p.o box
so then she went
curious to see like who is this charles
mcdowell wait so she was getting his
mail in her p.o box
yeah so okay i missed that part yeah she
was getting his mail in her p.o box and
then she went to the person that was
running the p.o box the hardware store
postal service sucks
well i know right he actually is old yes
it was his old p.o box he was talking
about how this was a pastor
that used to live there but then he
moved to asheville and so
she looked him up and it was this
charles mcdowell that was connected to
this case
so sketchy right and needless to say
that dad was driving greg's car that
night
tiff um they were actually family cars
all the cars that they owned so they
would rotate like who was driving that
could have been anyone in that car damn
so yeah um charles and his wife betty
mcdowell ended up separating because
once the affairs were kind of confirmed
good for you buddy
yeah yeah and then he resigned from
being a pastor and moved to asheville
where i don't know what he does now but
is he still alive i think he
might be still alive yeah i think he is
still alive yeah
give it to him jess we don't know a
little finger right to you it doesn't
matter what is
definitely no creepy [ __ ] yeah there's
enough
for sure so um i mentioned
that uh rhonda worked with
betty mcdowell greg her boyfriend's mom
and this charles mcdowell's wife um so
the company christmas party
she was worried about signing her name
up because she didn't want
betty and greg to be there um so
she signed it up last minute but then
betty did see it
and betty said that her and charles
mcdowell and their son greg were all
going to come to this party
and so ronda was like no if greg comes
she was talking to her mother
she's like if greg comes that i won't be
able to talk to anybody because he gets
really mad when i talk to anybody
so she wasn't gonna go to the party if
she found out that greg was also going
to the party
she also wanted to buy a new outfit and
if greg found out that she
bought a new outfit he would go crazy on
her so she was really bummed out
finding out that they were gonna go so
at the last minute they decided not to
go
the mcdowells but greg was not happy
about it he was very upset
does anything make greg happy no nothing
makes greg happy
no because psycho only her smile
possessive narcissist um so
yeah she goes to this party and she's
she feels great she has her new outfit
on and everything
and then she goes to stay with her
friend um
sherry and uh she before going to bed
it's 12 30 at night she said she was
gonna call greg to say goodnight
and she calls him and greg is very very
upset he's very mad because he's greg
and he's great because he's great and
all the reasons rhonda is like visibly
upset um
she's like holding back tears she
doesn't really cry or show emotions that
much but
she was like really upset and she goes i
guess that's it i guess i better
go then and then she hangs up the phone
and tells her friend
like hey i can't spend the night i think
me and greg are gonna break up
and um i couldn't i don't wanna
like how can you let her go i know i'm
like you can't let your friends go when
they're like
leaving the house like that well she's
especially in the middle of the night
yeah
like there's a lot of regret in all of
these people like if i would have just
like because uh rhonda had invited her
best friend jill but uh jill said no
because she had plans with her boyfriend
mark that night and to this day jill was
just like just kidding
jill well actually oh she's the third
son oh
my god but jill to this day she was so
[ __ ] i just feel like it's such a
rule that we need to pick up
like forever and ever that like if a
girl is having issues with her boyfriend
she shouldn't leave in the middle of the
night especially when he's like
physically abusive
a lot of times so they didn't know that
it was happening you know yeah she did
keep to herself a lot but like
i don't know if women we have intuition
like we should try to use it a little
bit more and just be like how about you
just wait until tomorrow i don't feel
comfortable letting you leave tonight
yeah i feel like we have to make that
like a thing amongst ourselves
but you know what i i think i get what
you're saying and i think you're right
but i picture like if any of you were at
my house like
you know if you were at my house and you
were going through a breakup and you're
like no i just have to get rid of it i
just have to figure it out i just have
to go do it
i would let you go because i'm like well
she's a pretty strong woman
like she's pretty independent hindsight
is 20 20.
hindsight is 20 20. well maybe we should
normalize that but we should normalize
that because
protection is so much greater also you
don't want your friend to talk to them
at the height of their emotions
you never know what's gonna happen yeah
like the middle of the night especially
people
drinking or something and it's yeah like
things weird things happen at night
fights escalate at night more than they
do in the daylight like i don't know
yeah and there um she did hide stuff
from her best friend a lot because her
best friend was very protective of her
and was like if i ever find out anything
i will make sure you guys break up
so there was this one time where they
were all um
jill her boyfriend mark and they were
always hanging out together they were
double dating together all the time
um so greg and ronda and jill and mark
were all
at some um like getaway together
and greg and ronda got in a fight
because ronda wouldn't have sex with him
and then greg went to the beach and
tried to pick up other girls
and then rhonda found out about it
[Music]
yeah god i hate this guy i know like so
many guys are like him too and it's
disgusting even if he didn't do it
just [ __ ] lock them up i know as i
was reading through these articles i'm
like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] think this you just
gotta you gotta out psycho them
yeah send me in you just gotta recognize
that first
red flag and [ __ ] peace out one red
flag you're out set it on fire
yeah also what was weird too there's a
lot of weird stuff
obviously but um when ronda's parents
found out she
that rhonda had died they called greg
right away and they're like
your girlfriend died and he took two
hours to get to their house
even though he only leaves lives 15
minutes away and when he got there he
was freshly showered and shaved
and he wouldn't he wouldn't make eye
contact with anybody he wouldn't talk to
anybody
and then later in the night um ronda's
mother
came up to try to hug him and as soon as
she
said what are we gonna do about rhonda
greg went to the bathroom and
vomited everywhere what yeah he couldn't
talk about rhonda
without throwing up oh my god he totally
did it he did or his dad did it and then
and then later after greg went home like
a few a day later
um jill and mark went to go see him to
see if he was doing okay
and his mom answered betty and was like
really annoyed that they were there
like just like look like wouldn't you
want people to console your son but she
was like why are you here
and then she just let them in and greg
wouldn't she knew about it too greg
wouldn't make eye contact with them he
wouldn't talk to them these are his best
friends
he wouldn't make eye contact with them
he just like sat
glazed over with the tv on and then as
they were leaving
greg comes running out and hands them a
box of condoms because he says that he
didn't want ronda's parents to find out
they were having sex
and then that's that's it so that's
where the nut comes in and that's
and that's the only part of the nut that
you know i gotta get it yeah i was
hoping there would be like it's not that
juicy
okay no juicy not just not juicy these
are using protection
yeah um okay some other weird things
there when rhonda left for work so she
had to work
before she had the party so it was on
like a thursday
and so everybody went to work and then
they went and changed and then they came
back for a party
so as she was going to work that day um
it was really really cold out but she
didn't have
a sweater she didn't have any overcoat
to wear and her mom was like
what where are your coats and she said
that one of her
sweaters was in mark's car because
him and mar mark and her went christmas
shopping for their friend jill's present
so then she left her sweatshirt in his
car and then
her letter jacket was with greg because
she left it at his house
so she didn't have a jacket to wear so
she picked out this old like
multicolored jacket
to wear to work that day and then
later after they discovered her vehicle
they found both the letter jacket
and this gray sweatshirt it was so greg
in the car
wow wait why like how what so why would
he just drop off
her sweater then that's weird so yeah
there were a few other items in the car
there was oh this is mark's car right
this is rhonda's car
wait so but she left her sweater in her
friend's boyfriend's car
yes picked up that she left it in greg's
club no no
she left um this is jill's boyfriend
jill's boyfriend
has her gray sweatshirt because they
went christmas shopping for jill's
present together
and rhonda left in his car um the letter
jacket she left with greg
greg had the letter jacket okay so this
is interesting too
on the night of her murder around the
same time so her murder happened around
um
like right after she left sherry's house
was 12 30 at night so
somewhere in the wee hours of the
morning around that same time
mark had just dropped jill off at her
house
at 12 30 and she remembers the time
because she had missed curfew by 30
minutes and she was worried that her
parents were going to get upset
and as she was saying goodbye to mark
she noticed ronda's sweatshirt in the
back of his
car and she asked him about it but it
was like nothing fishy or anything
because they were all good friends um
and he was like oh yeah she left it in
my car when we went christmas shopping
for your present
and joe was like oh do you want me to
give back to her and he's like oh no
i'll just see her i'll just give it to
greg when i see him
tomorrow so she's like okay whatever i
don't want to be late and i don't want
my parents to be bad she goes in her
house
and then she saw that sweatshirt in his
car that night
and that's the same one that was that
was in ronda's car
oh [ __ ] that same night when rhonda's
car was found and she was dead
so how did rhonda get that sweatshirt
and
that where ronda's car um was shot is
in direct route of where mark had to
travel to get back to his house
oh so he met up with greg and they both
somehow killed her
possibly there were two people that the
witness saw yeah because greg's car was
there
but then mark's connected to it with a
sweater yeah
and um in ronda's car she also had a
wooden bowl
that belonged to mark's parents
she's an amazing random she's mingling
with mark a little too much
and her car was completely cleaned out
and there was no clutter before the
party because
rhonda kept her car pretty clean she
also had in her car
a pink stuffed snake that greg had one
for her
when they were all at that outing that
getaway and they like
you know had an inside joke about it
because it's like a small pink snake
yeah it was their little thing yeah so
like tiny pink
sure does not like it probably acts like
it's very tiny this pink snake was
probably bigger it was about a foot
i hope that'd be bigger jesus there was
also a note from greg a handwritten note
that was found and i can't remem it was
it was unclear whether this was found on
her windshield or inside her car
it was just among the items that were
found um but
it was a handwritten note from greg
saying i will always love you
weird huh so let's get into some more
weird things about charles mcdowell
though because he's not off the hook
okay just cause we're talking about mark
and craig
i want to go back to him because he
led the funeral um rhonda's because he
was a pastor in the town and
rhonda's parents just were like he was
there on the night that uh rhonda died
they were like he was one of the people
that were over at the house
and touched her they didn't know about
that
so um they asked him to lead the funeral
so he did but the funeral was really
weird it was first of all like the
shortest funeral that anyone had ever
been to like it was just
really really brief and charles barely
said anything nice about rhonda
he just said like he barely knew her he
she went to dinner a few times
with the family and she had a nice smile
and that that was it
oh my god he's such a liar yeah and he's
like
it's so obvious when you're trying to
act like you don't know someone
yeah like you if you weren't guilty you
would why would you bring it up
you would have just added like you do
know her more than that but you're
trying to act like you don't whatever
charles
yeah which also was in conflict with
what he said later
he directly contradicted himself later
he tried to say that she was like a
daughter to him
but um during this eulogy he also
mentioned that he wasn't sure if ronda
was in hell or not
yeah which is super insensitive he's
rejecting us
he is a narcissist yeah and then
projecting right onto her no wonder
greg's the way he is and then later
um when friends and family were like why
did you say this because a lot of them
didn't had never met
charles mcdowell before this was the
first time they ever met him and they
were like man he must not
like rhonda and so they're like why did
you say this hell comment it was really
like
mean to say and he goes oh no i didn't
mean it in a in a mean way like i just
don't know her faith
and so a lot of good people end up in
hell you know
oh my god yeah we just don't i'm just
saying we don't
we don't yeah like why
say that you're a pastor you wouldn't
like why would you need to say that
there was no sympathy at all um and then
the song that he chose was all about
forgiveness
yeah and then the whole thing was a song
about was about forgiveness
it was just like hey forget and move on
forgive like god
has a plan like so you should just
forgive and move on
yeah and then also
uh like the mcdowells in general like
the mom the dad
um the sister the greg
they don't it didn't really show emotion
they would just kind of get angry
whenever rhonda was brought up
also later people were like why did you
ask um charles mcdowell to do the
funeral
they are asking rona's parents because
they had never met him before and she
was like well one he was
the father of my you know the boyfriend
but also like i think he did it and i
was kind of half hoping
hoping that he would confess in front of
everybody
oh my god the mom yeah rhonda's mom my
god
that's my kind of [ __ ] yeah yeah right
yeah so like one one instance uh her
friend
ronda's mom's friend linda asked charles
about greg and how he was doing
and he was just quickly like greg is
fine and uh linda was like i'm afraid
this will really hurt greg for some time
and
charles mcdowell was like no it won't
greg will be fine he's going to forget
rhonda and this part of his life and
he's not going to let it bother him oh
no greg did it
they're covering up for greg then he
went to ronda's mom and was like
hey um you should forget about rhonda
you should live for bobby and her son
robbie
like a car load of boys probably got
behind
a girl out at the time of night i
probably
went behind this girl at the time of
night and started
shooting at her when uh that's such a
[ __ ] made up yeah when
she didn't react one shot yeah shot and
then he said
you'll never know who did this he also
said that ronda would be dismayed if she
knew how
the mom was acting wait who said you'll
never know who did this
charles mcdowell the dad yeah and then
he said that ronda will
what rhonda would be dismayed if she
knew how the mom was acting
yeah gaslighting yeah exactly
um so later the hintons hired a private
investigator and invite and the private
investigator advised them to record all
conversations regarding rhonda's death
and charles mcdowell came over furious
after somebody
went to his house to interview him and
ask why the hintons thought that he had
murdered their daughter
he loved her like a like his own
daughter
and betty his wife even got her the job
which was later
proved to be untrue because the place
she was working was like no we hired her
because
we liked her work ethic yeah rhonda's
mom brought up
uh why did you say my daughter's
probably in hell then
and mr mcdowell was like miss henson
there's a lot of good people in hell
and then she told him about her
alcoholic father and that he was a good
man even though he drank and charles
said i hate people who drink
and then during the course of the
conversation um the reverend
charles mcdowell summarized his
whereabouts on that morning
of the december 23 22 1981
because the mom was like well then where
were you you're right and so he goes i
came through the crime
crime scene i stopped i asked what had
happened i thought she had passed out
run off the road and that was what
killed her
the police would not tell me what
happened they told me to come over to
your house
when i got there the sheriff was there i
called betty and greg
his wife and son and when rhonda called
uh greg
talked to her i didn't i didn't know
they had argued until the next day greg
acted normal he said she had gone to the
party alone and he was going to stay at
home
i went to cherries that was the
co-worker's house and came through
longview
and then he got on the um on the highway
i thought that was the route she would
have taken i've been to sheri's once to
pick rhonda up that's how i know where
sherry lived
i left the house about 2 30 a.m or 3 a.m
to go look for rhonda
but what's weird and then once again he
reiterated that the case would never be
solved
and that he told he told me nothing
would uh help rhonda now and other
people should not be hurt because of
this but later
sherry said he never picked up rhonda
from my house he has no idea where i
live
there's no way he would have known that
so
it's interesting it's very contradicting
[Music]
also that why is he so sure it's never
going to get solved
i know he's hiding projecting
yeah also um greg was adamant that he
picked rhonda up
in a a burgundy toyota
but the person that said he picked her
up was like no it was a blue
nova like with and when she saw the
unsolved murder
episode the unsolved mysteries episode
when they showed the car
she got chills down her spine because
she's like that's the car that greg was
driving
yeah that was him that belonged to
charles macdonald and people suck at
committing crimes
also charles mcdowell was a hunter oh of
course so he has plenty of guns
there's a murder weapon but i just don't
get why the dad would want to kill her
right you know what she would have did
it
i think maybe like the dad did something
to rhonda
and then somehow the son and the wife
found out
and then the charles ended up saying
like well she seduced me like she was
she was the one that came on to me and
then so that's when they were like well
we got to do something about this
and they they probably after and that's
why they're all covering up it's a whole
family of crazies
i don't think the mom was involved i
think she found out later and i think
like because a lot of women that are
super weak they she would just be upset
that the whole thing happened that
the dad touched the little girl because
you know like a lot of times abuse when
abuse happens to young women too like
even
when it's their own daughters like the
older women's get upset and they're just
like
they don't know how to deal with it so
it turns to anger and blame
like on the victory because they just
don't want it to be happening yeah and
they're like i can't believe that this
is even my life now so they just like
make it the victim's fault
for bringing it up yeah or like yeah for
even existing and for the
man to like abuse them like they blame
the
the younger girl so it's like i feel
like the mom was just like mad it
happened i don't think she was there for
the murder
i don't think or maybe she wasn't there
for the murder but i definitely feel
like that's the reason why there was so
much anger some sort of coming from that
it was the dad
that did something creepy for sure the
whole family knew and everyone's just
covering it up it's just a matter of who
did it in the future right
i think there's a son yeah the son did
it and the parents were covering up for
him or the other
then how did mark get her sweater from
mark's
car to her car what i think happened
with that is that um
he was driving home he saw greg's car
because it's a small town right and
there's only one highway
so i think he saw greg's car i was like
oh [ __ ] hey here's your girlfriend
yeah can you give this to rhonda that
probably ticked him off and that's why
he was so mad like how come you have
rhonda's [ __ ] speech like she's
[ __ ] my daddy
and she's [ __ ] my best friend i'm
gonna shoot this [ __ ]
yeah and then never love another man
yeah
and then like the the amount of stuff
that she had like the mismatched amount
of stuff
is kind of like when you go through a
breakup and you're getting all your
belongings back
from the person that you're breaking up
with so
it seems like they met up rhonda and
greg
met up greg gave her back all her stuff
probably
wanted to like resolve that that's how
he got her to leave his friends like
we're
we're breaking up right now you need to
come get your shoes like that
so i guess i better leave you know and
so she goes to meet up with him and
get his yeah those things and then maybe
as she's leaving he's like no i can't
[ __ ] deal with this
that's exactly what i think i honestly
also think that
it wasn't he didn't plan to
kill her i think he wanted to scare her
like maybe pop her tires
or like aim for like the just but then
he shot her right here
because if you look the bullet is aimed
downwards so
um but then the hill she was driving up
a sort of slant
so yeah i think he didn't mean to
hit her but still like but then why drag
her out
and then leave her on the side of the
road with her arms oh okay so that part
there was i told you there's a bunch of
suspects um one
group of suspects that got rolled out
right away were the people that were
first on the scene
so there were a couple party goers that
found her right away
and um i think they might have thought
she was a drunk driver
and was like trying to pull her out and
then realized that like
oh [ __ ] she's dead yeah
and um yeah left her and then went to
the police there was no dna stuff back
in there they were actually
yeah there was no dna and they were
actually really terrible with handling
the evidence everything was tampered
with
like they can't find like half of the
things anyway
yeah it was really bad so it's a lot a
lot of the reason why this case
goes unsolved also there were so many
detectives one of the detectives
analyzed that charles mcdowell um has
traits of a psychopath but appears to be
very intelligent and calculated
and it's more likely that maybe he
convinced greg that ronda was causing
him stress and grief and that if
anything were to happen to her that she
probably deserved it and the family
shouldn't suffer because of it
so he hides behind being a pastor
yeah yeah um one other thing that i
thought was kind of funny when i was
researching this case is that
psychics were involved three times they
used psychics a lot yeah investigations
i think when they can't find something
they're like they're so desperate that
they just are like [ __ ] it let's go to a
cycle it's so funny but they like don't
want to admit it but then they use them
a lot
yeah that's why that tv show was so good
yeah like
so the first psychic was hired by the
parents of rhonda cause they were just
so desperate they're like they wanted
answers so i can understand that
and the psychic said she knows for sure
that it was charles mcdowell
the second psychic um was hired
i don't know if hired or she just wanted
to contribute um
after it had been so many amount of
years uh
another detective met with her and
um the detective says that he does not
believe in psychics at all
but then this psychic told him a word
that has such significance to him
that nobody else would have known this
word or what it meant and so it sent
chills down his spine and he
agreed to like meet with her and this
psychic
said that it was definitely greg
mcdowell
and that it was a passion killing like
he wanted rona to stay and she decided
to leave and then he picked up a gun and
just
shot but didn't like intend to kill her
and then he felt incredibly guilty
for what he'd done and so she thinks the
parents just try to convince him to
forget about it
yeah and um and then the third psychic
drew pictures of who she thought
i don't know if it was a hiroshi but who
they thought killed ronda and
she drew two pictures not knowing very
much about the case
and one looked exactly like greg
mcdowell and the
other one looked exactly like mark's new
wife
faith which was so weird and freaked
faith out she's like i don't know why
this we're going to happen with jill and
mark
oh yeah so jill and mark broke up
because mark was like not
into ronda's death at all
mark was like get over it like she died
and jill was like just
totally torn it was her best friend and
so she he didn't console her at
all he was just like i just don't want
to think about it anymore so they ended
up breaking up because of that
and then within a year he ends up
marrying this
girl fake dude all these guys suck yeah
yeah
and faith was a mutual friend of all of
theirs like she knew wrong
she knew greg she's oh wait so faith was
already in that circle
kind of but like as um like they're just
an acquaintance
and then they got married a year after
breaking up less than a year
oh my god and jill went to the wedding
what
i know it's tea guys how small it's a
small town okay
it's a small town i could never yeah
but that's how the case remains now
there's no that's
it like there's not enough evidence they
tried to take dna samples they did find
dna samples of someone unknown um on one
of the outfits she was wearing
but they are not allowed to take dna
samples of people that they
suspect unless those people commit
crimes so or they volunteer their dna
samples but
um yeah so they really like can't reopen
the case because they don't have enough
evidence oh wait so right now you can't
collect someone's dna
you can't unless they get caught with a
crime then their dna gets sampled and um
do it like they can 23 and me they can
request it
that's why there's those conspiracies
that like they want everyone's dna
suspect if um they can get a judge to
court order it no
um yeah but they'd have to have enough
probable cause just do it like they do
on tv just like offer them a cup of
water and be like oh
thank you like a piece of gum and just
follow him to the trash and then just
frame them for a different crime
and then get the dna and then link them
to that crowd
the psychic that's the second chaos the
one that thinks greg did it um the
second one
that got that word that meant a lot to
the detective she described greg's
office to a t
had never been there and said to look
for this picture of his wife
that's sitting on a certain shelf and
like described it in detail and said
that the wife actually looks a lot like
rhonda
and so greg got married after all this
and the wife can't believe a woman would
marry him yeah
and then so she probably didn't so when
he went to greg's office
he found everything exactly like the
psychic said wouldn't this be like in
the public eye
this whole case was in the public eye
and a [ __ ] still married greg yeah
yeah but like she's also friends this
part wasn't really publicized
like this didn't get publicized until
the 2000s so it was like 20 years later
yeah
damn yeah because in the original
information no wait so what did what did
they find by the wife's picture
uh that was she was just describing the
the office yeah
she just approved like this is the guy
that i'm talking about maybe the second
psychic seems like the most legit i
think so
i i mean what's her number i know right
right that's what i was thinking too
she's already dead she was like 60 in
the 80s
so i'm thinking it's greg i'm just going
to say it what the [ __ ] is i don't know
it's all a legend huh greg what are you
up to these days
right you got a safe engineer [ __ ] you
yeah creepy what do you guys think i
think it was greg and the family's
trying to cover it up yeah yeah
i think so too yeah um i mean the
original detective on the scene
said i think it's the boyfriend but they
didn't he didn't have enough
evidence and so they kind of shushed him
why is mark
such a a suspect though other than this
because of the sweatshirt and he
couldn't recall it
and they think the reason he can't
recall what
where the handoff happened is because
earlier that morning he had gone to the
emergency room
because of an injury on his back and so
he's put on three different medications
and so they think like it kind of just
[ __ ] with his memory
also gosh there were so many details but
like um greg mcdowell
failed his first polygraph test oh those
aren't reliable
yeah but they're not admissible in court
so um his dad was like so what [ __ ] off
and then the second one he passed like a
a year later
so we don't we don't know it's very
unsolved there's not enough evidence
but the first the first report was that
there was two guys in the
blue yeah could have been charles so
could have been
the family saw because charles also had
some really
you know weird contradictory things like
they asked why didn't you show up to the
christmas party like why'd you change
your mind
and betty said oh because charles had a
stomach virus
but then later interviewed separately
their daughter said that the dad had
other things to do that night
and that's why he couldn't go to the
party too many lives also charles
went out on a flight like left on a
flight out of town
the day after finding out about ronda's
death wow randomly like who
like why we don't know we don't know
there's so many why's not enough answers
but
you know our heart goes out to rhonda
hinson and her family
we're sorry one day and
um oh she's haunting the [ __ ] out of
greg right yeah right
if that if that exists i hope so for her
rattle some chains [ __ ] yeah
stop in the balls and his [ __ ] dad
yeah [ __ ] that dad probably done by now
she didn't even get to do anything i
feel so bad for her no she was so young
19. geez
anyway let us know who you think done it
in the in the comments hopefully you're
all boozed up and a drunk detective and
uh
you can solve the case for us but um
other than that let us know if you like
these if you want us to keep doing more
murder mystery moons and if there's any
moons yeah
it is a new moon there's a new one too
we're going to do ourselves
oh yeah we got to do a new moon ritual
coming right up yeah check out that vlog
too
it's happening um yeah subscribe like us
all that stuff and if there's any cases
you want us to talk about let us know in
the comments we love you
we love you bye but not you greg stay
safe don't let your friends leave
without
protecting them yeah protect women
protect women's
[Music]